the Joe Rogan experience yeah I moved to
New York with $400 and I got bedbugs the
first year landlord died of AIDS whoa
and I got mugged three times in the
first year oh my god it was hell man not
that like what knifepoint done point
well I was mostly my fault I'm victim
blaming here but I I was always such a
blackout drunk that I was just like
asking to be mugged I would fall asleep
and wake up and guys were going through
my [ __ ] one time I fell asleep on Hell's
Kitchen member the bar Rudi's know that
you got a free hot dog with every beer
so it was a hot spot but I remember
being so drunk they threw me out and I
was walking down 9th Avenue and I was
like I just gotta lay down for a minute
I'm so tired
cuz I had to go when you had that haul
to Brooklyn on the subway that would
take two three hours sometimes really oh
yeah at that at 4:00 in the morning yeah
two three hours because the trains
change and they never show up and you
know and then the garbage train comes it
takes forever and I live in Crown
Heights man which is like way out so I
fell asleep in this little alcove and I
woke up and four or five guys are going
through my [ __ ] they're blockbusting and
I'm like oh [ __ ] and I was like he goes
he's getting up and he hit me I went out
again and they took my keys my phone my
joke book I mean my wallet and starting
from scratch with no money you gotta buy
somehow get a MetroCard but you have no
wallet to get the MetroCard you got no
Greek credit card to get the wallet I
mean it's it's brutal how'd you get
bought would you do I just had to walk
home which took forever and then I think
I jumped the turnstiles got home and
then you know you find your roommate you
call your mom and she helps you Wow I
fell asleep
oh this is a crazy story I fell asleep
on the subway I went like four stops
past mine in Brooklyn and I got out and
I was like I'll walk it it's a nice
night I see five guys in the corner
right out of central casting shooting
dice thug thugged-out guys on the corner
drinking 40s and I go I'm gonna cross
the street these guys look a little
shady and I walk cross street and now an
older guys coming to her white beard big
older black guy and he gets up to me and
I had an old iPod he goes give me that
radio and I go it's not a radio thinking
that would like you know turn him away
and he goes just give it to me I god I
don't think so and he grabs
so I grabbed but now we're tugging and
he picks me up and he's slamming me
against a business-like you know in the
metal gate closes then pow pow and I'm
kicking him I'm punching him and I can't
I think he was on PCP or something and
before I know what those five guys run
over and just beat the [ __ ] out of him
I'm talking he hits the ground that
kicked him in the face and I'm just like
uh I grab my iPod and I get out of there
so those five guys helped you they saved
my life yeah holy [ __ ] I I talked to a
cop about it like a month later and he
was like oh those were drug dealers and
they can't have some white kid getting
killed in your Nate in the neighborhood
so they had to make a choice and I was
like wow thank God for drugs yeah you
can't judge I totally judge those guys
[Applause]